今山肇社長です
骨だけ飲み多少けど
そもそも前提で今日の動画なんですけどもこちらこちらですね阿部られるお箸という
ものがございまして今度食べられるお箸何かと言いますと
食べられるお箸なんですよね前枚あるなってるんですけど本当にあるとは思わんですよ
コレですよコレコレコレめっちゃはっきり書いてありますねちょっと開けてみます
おぉあっすぐねカバー色ただに出てきたの証ですねホラーもめっちゃ普通の8室から
コンビニでは出てこないな
ドッグフード音がドッグフードの味がするね箸くれるねやばいなあごちそうさまでした
せてそのままてグーッ
チャンネルわけなんですがパッチャー素顔が気だ
艦隊は行って味が畳痩せたらどんな鮮やかにただけでこういう食べられるをはずなん
ですけどもやっぱりでお箸で食べる人いないんですよで今日は畑の土が今から行くん
ですけども銀行の食べられるを斜字体ちょっとあまり話題にもなってないんですよ多分
もこんなことを知らないと思うんでもう一つで肇社長がご飯を食べ終わった後にお
箸置き
ペタろういう反応するのか見ていこうと思いますよシンプルですね頂点でせ普段食べ
ないもの食べるのマジでやばいですから果たしてどんな反応してくれるのでしょうか
このタイプの人もコンビニで手に入んないんで
で畑の部屋の台所高でしまっておくところから始めようと思いますよ行こうよ
バッハ
わー
se
wha iaea
4を
誰ゴルーグみましょうはぁ
ああああああ
便でもらえるカード選びましたらです
0拍手あと俺
うわぁやられたほんとそれ
なぜ別棟でどういうこと
ピックをつないだ
いうのができん
おいた下手な絵だっていくん
飲んでるから
うさをお願いするか落ち来たーーー早朝ですよ
まあおさらいっても誰って言うお茶を持ってないけどなあー
ああああああ
amaran
[音楽]
ブーバーソーサー
ハイツ度た子いないかないただけましたこれじゃんまん
めっちゃ先どうか女は最後
h いって必要思ったっ
me
あっ
はいえー
2人がクレストの
どうぞ hey
誰も来ないんだけどねええ
use
丹村は大会でもできるけど
ああああああ
nara
[音楽]
par
rar
うざいよ
んんじゃねぇええっ
ライダーだからん
me
teame
ううっうううう
car
うううううっ
というわけであります食べられるをは水ドッキーでスター
なってねーんだ無理だなんもう
碁盤を上限商品だねぇ